supongamos que voy a la frutería y me
encuentro con que las guayabas tienen
30% de descuento así es que hay un 30%
menos
guayabas además me dicen que esto es
solo por hoy solo hoy me decido entonces
a comprar algunas guayabas así que
compro 6 guayabas compro 6 guayabas y al
final de cuentas cuando paso a la caja
ya descontado los impuestos no podemos
pensar que voy a un estado donde los
abarrotes no pagan impuestos así es que
por las 6 guayabas ya haciéndome mi
descuento del 30% me cobran un total de
12 dólares con 60 centavos 12 dólares 60
centavos y este es el precio ya con el
descuento del 30% por seis guayabas
llego a casa y mi esposa me dice oye sal
puedes comprar dos guayabas más mañana
le digo que por supuesto y el día
siguiente voy y compro 2 guayabas más
así es que dos guayabas más pero ahora
ya no está la oferta la oferta era el
día anterior cuando compre seis guayabas
así es que cuánto me van a costar esas
dos guayabas cuánto le van a costar esas
dos guayabas al precio completo
precio
completo
una buena manera de empezar es encontrar
cuánto costarían esas seis guayabas al
precio completo este es el precio de
descuento este es el precio de descuento
pero cuánto me costaría en esas seis
guayabas si las hubiera pagado al precio
completo hagamos un poco de álgebra aquí
déjame elegir un color adecuado para el
álgebra este gris está bien digamos que
x es igual al costo de 6 guayabas al
costo de 6 guayabas a precio completo
básicamente si tomamos 30% de este costo
vamos a obtener 12 puntos 60 hagamos
esto así es que si tenemos el costo de 6
guayabas a precio completo y le restamos
el 30% que es punto 30 o podemos ponerlo
simplemente como punto 31 déjame
escribir lo mejor así mi esposa siempre
me insiste en que escribe el 0 antes del
punto decimal que sería x 0.30
el valor de x que es el descuento que
estoy tomando el 30% de descuento del
costo real de las guayabas del costo al
precio completo y esto debe de ser igual
a los 12 dólares con 60 centavos que
pague esto es igual a 12.60 simplemente
reste el 30% del precio completo y ahora
sólo hacemos álgebra podemos imaginar
que hay un 1 aquí en frente x es igual a
1 por x una x menos punto 30 x es igual
a punto 7 x lo cual también podemos
escribir como punto 70 x 10.7 x que es
igual a y una vez que te acostumbras a
este tipo de problemas podrías llegar
directamente este paso considerando que
el 70% de x punto 7 por x es igual a
12.60 si estás descontando 30% te queda
70% del precio completo así es que
podrás llegar directamente este paso
cuando te acostumbres a estos problemas
resolvemos para x dividiendo ambos lados
entre puntos 70 dividiendo ambos lados
entre puntos 7 obtenemos que x es igual
a 12.60 entre punto 7
usar la calculadora aquí pero siempre es
bueno seguir practicando las divisiones
con decimales
así es que 0.7 que divide a 12.60 para
esto vamos a multiplicar por 10 ambos
números corremos el punto decimal hacia
el lado derecho en ambos casos del lado
izquierdo nos queda simplemente 7 y del
lado derecho hacemos lo mismo
corremos un lugar a la derecha el punto
decimal aquí va el punto decimal y vamos
a dividir 126 entre 7 nos vamos a
olvidar desde cero y este punto
dividamos 126 entre 7 12 entre 7 es
igual a 11 por 7 7 hacemos la resta 12 7
es igual a 5 bajamos el 6 56 entre 7 es
igual a 8 8 por 7 56 que restamos para
obtener un residuo de 0 la división
resulta en 18 y como no hay nada después
del punto decimal en nuestro caso son 18
dólares así es que x es igual a 18
dólares recuerda lo que es x x es el
precio completo de 6 agua de 6 guayabas
no sé por qué estoy pensando en
aguacates x es el precio completo de 6
guayabas pero la pregunta es cuánto me
costarán 2 guayabas al precio completo
bueno este que tenemos aquí es el precio
completo de 6 guayabas vamos a obtener
primero el precio completo de una
guayaba para esto dividimos 18 entre 6
lo cual nos da 3 dólares vamos a pagar 3
dólares por guayaba
precio completo pero nos tiene el costo
de dos guayabas entonces simplemente
multiplicamos entonces tres dólares por
dos guayabas para obtener seis dólares
otra manera hacer esto es si 18 es el
precio de 6 guayabas y 2 es la tercera
parte de 6 el precio de 2 guayaba sería
18 dólares entre 36 dólares hagamos una
revisión rápida lo que hicimos dijimos
que por 6 guayabas pagamos con precio de
descuento 12 dólares 60 eso es 30 por
ciento menos del precio total o
podríamos decir que esto es 70% del
precio completo así es que si restas el
30 por ciento haciendo x el costo de 6
guayabas a precio completo aquí estamos
restando el 30 por ciento de ese costo
para obtener 12 dólares con 60 centavos
eso equivale establecer que el 70% del
precio completo es 12.60 resolvimos esto
algebraica mente dividiendo entre punto
7 ambos lados y obtuvimos que x el
precio completo de 6 guayabas es 18
dólares lo que equivale a 3 dólares por
guayaba o 6 dólares por
guayabas en fin espero que esto te haya
sido útil